en décembre 2014 j'ai rendez vous chez
mon gynécologue ça fait un peu plus d'un
an que je suis mariée heureuse et on a
très envie d'avoir des enfants
et donc j'ai rendez vous chez mon
gynécologue et qui me dit
madame aaron va on devait parler d'un
sujet mais on va parler d'autre chose
j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle à vous
annoncer
vos analyses révèlent que vous faites
une récidive de votre cancer
comment vous dire que
c'est une annonce à laquelle je
m'attends absolument pas
à laquelle je ne suis pas préparé
et qui me heurte de plein fouet
c'est encore pire
que l'annoncent de la première du
premier cancer parce que finalement ben
je sais ce que ça veut dire
déjà passé par là
et j'ai vraiment aucune envie d'y
retourner
première pensée
plutôt logique
cela possible on commence
mais pourquoi
et puis la suivante qui sûr quasi
immédiatement
ouf
je vais pas me poser
je vais pouvoir souffler
imaginez peut-être la surprise
quand cette pensée surgi
pourquoi j'ai besoin d'un second cancer
pour me libérer quelque chose
pourquoi c'est un second cancer
qui m'a finalement fait découvrir et
réalisé
qu'en faisant des petites choses
je pouvais arriver un épanouissement
intérieur qui aujourd'hui me fait dire
oui j'avais bien
oui je suis heureuse
oui je suis apaisé
malgré ces obstacles
ou peut-être grave
et pourtant
après cette première maladie on aurait
pu penser que tout allait très bien
cette première maladie qui venu
s'inviter dans ma vie de jeune femme de
28 ans fraîchement amoureuse de celui
dont je sais que nous allons cheminer
ensemble tant que la vie nous est prêtée
jeune femme qui a fait de belles études
comme on dit et qui s'est lancé dans sa
carrière professionnelle avec
enthousiasme en
essai un peu dans cet état d'esprit que
je vais traverser ces neuf mois de
traitement en prenant les choses comme
elles viennent
les unes après les autres sans trop me
poser de questions
centrum écouter
et surtout sans entendre ce qu'on essaye
de me dire
parce que les médecins ont bien essayé
de me dire attention charlotte
à l'avenir il va falloir lever le pied
attention charlotte
il va falloir voir garder des réserves
plutôt que lé puiser dedans
continuellement
mais ça c'est un discours que j'entends
pas parce que lâcher tourné vers
l'avenir j'ai des projets plein la tête
à commencer par celui d'aller vivre à
l'étranger avec mon amoureux
et puis finalement basse et la tête
haute avec le sourire que je traverse
sept neuf mois traitement parce que oui
fondamentalement ça va je trouve que
c'est c'est supportable et puis ça va
s'arrêter de toute façon ça va finir par
passer
donc on y va on supporte ça finira par
s'arrêter
et puis mon entourage est très
réconfortant
on me dit que je suis forte que je suis
une battante
oui mais
cette bataille il s'arrête quand
exactement
parce que j'ai commencé à faire des
efforts
pour retrouver ma vie d'avant
j'en ai fait un peu
un peu tout le temps
plus en plus important
mais cette fatigue qui étaient là en
permanence
fatigue physique fatigue psychologique
fatigue émotionnelle
et puis ces troubles de la concentration
ces trous de mémoire
qui sont en fait des conséquences des
traitements contre le cancer et qui
durent bien longtemps après les
traitements
pourtant j'ai essayé de reprendre la vie
d'avant j'ai repris le travail
et au bout d'un an
difficile de reprendre son rythme et de
le garder ce rythme que je connaissais
bien avant
j'ai cherché un autre travail
mais comment expliquer ces quelques
trous ces quelques mois trou que j'avais
dans mon cv et puis comment ne pas
parler aussi de ses problèmes de fatigue
le fatigabilité ces problèmes de
concentration dont je souffrais en
permanence comme les trois quarts des
patients qui ont ce type de traitement
j'ai pas trouvé
alors j'ai décidé prendre les études
pour apprendre parce que j'aime ça parce
que je sais faire
j'ai appris le chinois
bien rapide excellente d'ailleurs
pour essayer d'améliorer les problèmes
de concentration et de et de mémoire
mais
avec tout ça
finalement je cherchais quelque chose je
cherchais à retrouver une confiance en
moi
une estime de moi
une reconnaissance sociale
et j'ai mis toute mon énergie
jusqu'à ce beau jour de décembre 2014 je
me suis retrouvé devant mon gynécologue
à me dire
où
je vais pouvoir me poser
je vais pouvoir souffler
et finalement ce moment ça a été une
énorme prise de conscience
c'est là je me suis rendu compte que
j'avais un choix à faire parce que j'en
pouvais plus
soit je sombrais à soi je trouver
quelque chose pour aller mieux
a finalement c'est l'instinct de survie
qui l'a emporté
et j'ai compris qu'à un moment donné je
pouvais plus me battre comme ça pour
essayer à tout prix de retrouver ma vie
d'avant je m'épuise je m'épuise est j'y
arrivais pas
et forcément une autre façon de faire
et c'est comme ça que j'ai commencé à
mettre en place la politique des petits
pas alors j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir une main tendue
par mon mari par mes proches
mais j'ai surtout décidé
d'accepter cette main tendue et de me
tourner d'abord vers moi même
et de m'écouter
je suis à découvrir
des choses simples comme le soutien
psychologique
le yoga la méditation le pilates
et petit à petit
je commence à me sentir mieux
alors que j'étais en plein traitement de
chimiothérapie
je vous assure que c'est pas agréable
mais quand même
je me sentais mieux
alors quand même comme pourquoi comment
est-ce que c'était possible c'est quoi
ce changement qui était en train de se
mettre en place
finalement ces activités
que j'invitais petit à petit dans mon
quotidien
la marche
la respiration pour calmer les angoisses
l'hypnose pour mieux gérer les
situations de stress
le pilates le yoga pour être mieux dans
mon corps mais être mieux dans mon
esprit aussi
et bien toutes ces petites activités
ont permis de me faire changer de
perspective sur les choses en
un beau jour ça m'a vraiment frappé
comme une évidence
j'ai compris la signification d'un
caractère chinois le dao qui veut dire
le cheminement la voix
c'est le chemin qui compte
c'est pas l'objectif en soi
et puis d'ancêtres finalement déquilibre
de vie
j'ai fini par comprendre que c'est le
mot équilibre qu'il fallait que je
regarde l'equilibre par définition ces
échanges en s'émouvant et ça se
redéfinit tout le temps
et c'est comme ça que petit à petit
les compris que ben c'est le cheminement
qui comptait ils n'ont pas le schéma de
vie
parce que fondamentalement
ce mois je me battais temps c'était
cette idée de ma vie je m'étais fait
est qu'avec ce premier cancer mais il y
avait eu ce sentiment d'injustice
de devoir faire des choix par défaut
ce sentiment de devoir faire des efforts
surhumains en permanence
et puis le second cancer qui m'a mené
finalement sur le chemin et qui me
faisait comprendre que ben
ce qui compte c'est au jour le jour le
fait d'aller mieux
d'être heureux
c'est comme ça que
deux patientes je suis devenu
accompagnantes
en répondant aux appels d'autres
personnes touchées par le cancer
j'ai choisi de me former à la méthode
pilates
est une méthode de renforcement
musculaire
je pouvais pratiquer avec des personnes
qui étaient en pleine forme comme moi
j'étais en pleine chimiothérapie fatigue
et nauséeuse avec un corps raide est
plutôt un corps d'une femme de 98 ans
plutôt que 34 et pourtant j'y arrive et
quand même
méthode éminemment adaptable à la
personne
j'ai choisi de me former ici à
montpellier à la faculté de médecine
pour devenir patients partenaires pour
faire le relais entre le patient et
l'équipe soignante
et puis j'ai choisi de devenir
entrepreneur
d'abord en enseignant la méthode pilates
et puis ensuite en créant ma propre
société mais charlotte avec mon mari
grâce à laquelle on accompagne d'autres
personnes touchées par le cancer
aujourd'hui c'est ce que je fais
je chemine avec d'autres personnes
de façon à prendre en compte dans leurs
envies leurs besoins et de faire ces
petits pas de les intégrer doucement
dans leurs habitudes de vie
de façon à leur transmettre cette
expérience
finalement en changeant de point de vue
sur les choses en changeant de
perspectives
en faisant des toutes petites choses
pour se sentir mieux au quotidien et
c'est comme ça peut-être qu'on arrivait
plus facilement à laisser de côté ces
grands schémas de vie on peut se faire
et qu'on arrive à se recentrer sur
l'essentiel
d'être mieux et plus heureux au
quotidien
et je vois il ya
heureusement y'a pas besoin de passer
par une maladie grave pour se rendre
compte de ça
pour opérer des petits changements comme
ça dans notre vie
finalement il suffit de se poser les
questions régulièrement
comment je me sens en ce moment
mon équilibre de vie actuels 1
convient-il
merci
[Applaudissements]